Trascrizione: ila S.
Revisore: Emanuele Francesco Pecora
Non ho nessun tipo di esperienza...
non sono un esperto in niente,
non ho fatto formazioni particolari,
tutta la mia esperienza viene
da una profonda curiosità
nelle cose, in quello che vedo,
in quello che incontro.
E questo è quello che faccio
quotidianamente, l'unica cosa che faccio.
Quindi la cosa che ho pensato, intanto,
di poter fare, è presentarmi,
dirvi chi sono, da dove vengo, cosa faccio
e poi, magari, vi interesserà qualcosa.
Quando mi chiedono
che cosa faccio come lavoro
beh la cosa più facile da dire è:
sono un fotografo,
che è la risposta più semplice e diretta.
In realtà quello che faccio
è un miscuglio di cose,
fondamentalmente
seguire le mie passioni.
Ho sempre seguito le mie passioni,
seguito quello che avevo voglia di fare,
e spessissimo sono poi diventati lavori
strada facendo.
Una delle cose che ho fatto,
qualche anno fa,
è stato creare uno spazio di coworking
a Roma, nel 2008,
uno spazio come questo,
che mi ha portato nel mondo
dell'economia collaborativa,
della partecipazione,
della collaborazione.
Un'altra delle mie passioni è viaggiare,
di provare le cose in prima persona.
Questo miscuglio di esperienze
ha fatto sì che ho iniziato
a girare e a fotografare
molti eventi e spazi in tutto il mondo
dove avvenivano cose
molto spesso legate
al mondo dell'economia collaborativa.
Attualmente mi occupo di un progetto
che si chiama CoPass
e che permette a gente come me
di lavorare ovunque nel mondo,
appoggiandosi agli spazi di coworking.
Quello che mi piace fare,
quotidianamente, è sperimentare,
fare esperienze, trovare anche altri modi
di vivere la condivisione.
Quando la condivisione non è
una piattaforma web,
un Facebook, un Twitter,
ma è un modo di vivere,
un modo di vivere reale,
quotidiano, di vita.
Ho portato qui alcuni esempi di cose
che mi hanno colpito, andando in giro,
per farvi capire più o meno
di che cosa si tratta.
Qui per esempio eravamo in Senegal,
e questa famiglia non è la nostra famiglia
erano semplicemente le persone
che abitano attualmente nella casa
dove mia moglie ha abitato da piccola.
Pochi minuti dopo
abbiamo fatto questa foto.
C'è stata un'accoglienza da parte
di persone completamente sconosciute
come se fossimo della famiglia.
Abbiamo mangiato insieme,
ci hanno addirittura vestito da africani,
ci hanno fatto dei regali, e tutto questo
è successo in mezz'ora, pochissimi minuti.
Spessissimo qui in Europa, bussando
a una porta di uno sconosciuto e dicendo
"ho abitato qui quando ero piccolo"
[la reazione è] "Ok, arrivederci."
Invece qui siamo entrati in contatto,
spesso adesso ci sentiamo.
Un'altra esperienza che mi ha colpito molto
è questa scuola in Cambogia,
non so se questo avviene in tutte
le scuole della Cambogia,
o per puro caso ho trovato questa qui.
Questi bambini arrivano
mezz'ora prima dei professori.
Arrivano a scuola
e iniziano a pulire la scuola,
bruciano tutte le sporcizie
che hanno trovato,
si occupano della scuola senza nessuna
presenza di professori e di insegnanti.
Quindi sono i primi a occuparsi
della pulizia della scuola
e che tutto funzioni bene
durante la giornata di studio.
Poi vanno a comprarsi da soli la merenda
e poi aspettano che arrivino i professori.
Questo mi ha stupito enormemente
perché il senso di responsabilità
e di cura che hanno per lo spazio
è impressionante,
rispetto magari a bambini di qui,
in Europa o in America,
dove si ha l'impressione che non abbiano
alcun rispetto per il luogo dove studiano.
Il capoclasse poi si occupa di metterli
in fila e di fare l'alzabandiera,
e poi, solo in questo momento,
arrivano gli adulti
e comincia la giornata di studio.
Questo è un altro caso
che è veramente particolare,
tra l'altro come modo di condivisione
per tantissimi casi.
È un'isola del Lago Titicaca,
l'isola di Taquile
Queste persone hanno deciso,
dopo un primo inizio di turismo normale,
di promuovere un turismo sostenibile.
Quindi hanno rifiutato
qualsiasi tipo di turismo di massa,
non ci sono hotel,
non ci sono strutture turistiche,
l'unico modo di andare sull'isola
è essere ospitati dalle famiglie locali
e tutto il beneficio fatto
da questo tipo di turismo
va a tutta la comunità,
non solo alla famiglia che vi ospita.
Questo è un momento molto particolare,
è stato interessante chiedergli
cosa stava avvenendo e perché:
si stavano scambiando
delle foglie di coca,
foglie di coca che sono molto utili
in alta quota,
per supportare
l'ossigenazione del sangue.
Ed è un modo di dirsi buongiorno,
un modo di salutarsi,
con uno scambio di foglie di coca,
per assicurarsi che tutta la popolazione
abbia abbastanza coca
per stare bene.
Quindi la prima cosa che si fa,
incontrandosi,
è assicurarsi che tutti abbiano
una quantità sufficiente per stare bene.
Su quest'isola ci sono tre leggi.
Uno: "non mentire";
due: "non rubare";
tre: "non oziare,
fare sempre qualche cosa".
Questo fa sì che le persone
siano regolate da queste tre norme,
che derivano dagli Inca,
e sull'isola ci sia una vita
molto gradevole, molto condivisa.
Per esempio mi ha stupito molto
che è proibito avere cani.
Mi sono chiesto: Perché?
[Sono] animali domestici.
Perché il cane, in Perù,
è il mezzo di difesa,
il sistema di sicurezza
più economico in circolazione,
e il fatto che qualcuno avesse un cane
e quindi volesse proteggere la sua casa,
mostrava la non fiducia
che aveva negli altri.
Quindi se qualcuno nella comunità
vuole avere un cane,
deve chiedere a tutti gli altri
l'autorizzazione per avere un cane
solo per compagnia, e rassicurare che
non ha, appunto, problemi di sicurezza.
Un'altra cosa che mi ha impressionato,
sempre sulla stessa isola,
è la loro apertura all'innovazione.
Perché non hanno un rifiuto
dell'evoluzione
ma hanno una specie
di intelligenza collettiva
- perché le decisioni vengono prese
da tutta la comunità.
Per esempio in questo caso hanno deciso
di investire tutti i proventi del turismo
in pannelli solari,
per avere un minimo di energia elettrica
sufficiente per una lampadina per casa,
praticamente,
e per poter pompare l'acqua
dal lago fino alla torre dell'acqua.
L'altra cosa particolare
è che queste persone
rifiutano l'uso della forza animale,
e quindi la torre d'acqua
è stata portata
da tutta l'intera comunità a piedi,
dal lago fino in cima alla collina.
Se vedete le foto
è veramente impressionante,
ed è ovviamente una cosa
che può esser fatta
solo se tutta la comunità partecipa.
Facendo questo tipo di ragionamento
mi sono reso conto
un po' di quello che, volente o nolente,
faccio quotidianamente,
e l'ho assimilato un po'
a quello che succede con le api,
quello che fanno le api con i fiori.
Che cosa fanno le api con i fiori?
Volano da un fiore a un altro
e impollinano i fiori.
Quello che è interessante,
è che il loro primo scopo
non è impollinare i fiori.
L'ape va solo a cercare
il nettare per fare il miele.
Quindi il suo scopo principale
non è impollinare.
Il suo scopo principale,
il suo obiettivo è ben altro.
Involontariamente, avviene questo.
In parallelo è un po' - più o meno -
quello che mi sento di fare.
Il mio scopo principale
non è diffondere delle idee
o portarle a destra e a sinistra.
Involontariamente,
con la mia curiosità,
io personalmente vado, viaggio
e cerco di scoprire delle cose nuove,
e involontariamente porto
queste informazioni, queste nozioni,
a destra e sinistra nelle varie culture.
Volevo sottolineare
che lo scambio avviene
completamente in maniera involontaria.
Io non so quello che vi potrà colpire
delle foto, delle immagini
o delle storie che vi ho raccontato.
Magari niente, magari tutto,
magari vi permette di aprire un'attività
o di cambiare modo di pensare.
Ma non è né il mio scopo,
né sotto il mio controllo.
Non sono io a controllare
quello che prendo
e non sono io a controllare quello
che voi recepite.
Questo funziona, secondo me,
solo a due condizioni:
la prima condizione è
che la persona che si muove,
si sposta, viaggia,
lo faccia con curiosità
per poter prendere le cose.
Se si viaggia senza curiosità,
quello che trovate,
quello che potrete portare a casa,
sono dei selfie con i monumenti.
Se invece guardate i dettagli,
fate domande,
cercate di capire
che cosa vi sta succedendo intorno,
riuscite ad avere informazioni,
a catturare informazioni.
L'altra parte,
che è altrettanto importante,
è la condivisione.
Perché se io facessi viaggi
del tutto personali,
per carità, trovo me stesso,
cresco, eccetera,
ma non ho nessun modo
di condividere queste informazioni,
è un sapere che resta del tutto personale.
Nel momento in cui queste informazioni
le condivido indistintamente,
chiunque può assumerle e farle proprie.
E questo è il mio modo
di "cucinare" il cambiamento.
(Applausi)